ان تعود الى منزلك مطمئنا انك ستجد اسرتك
في امان هذا يساوي الكثير عند عبد اللطيف
حامد المقيم في مصر منذ سنوات بعد ان كاد
القلق يفتك به خوفا على اسرته التي كانت
تحاول الهروب من الاشتباكات الدائره في
السودان ووصلت بسلام الى مصر منذ ثلاثه
ايام انا كنت جالي جدا وكنت متابعا
بالتليفون عبر التلفونات وعبر الواتساب
لحظه انه الاتصال اتقطع بيني وبينه بكون
دايما خائف وعايش في رعب شديد انه البلد
ما امنه يعني حتى لحد الحمد لله لحد ما
وصلوا اسطوان وكنت متابعهم خطوه بخطوه
وكلمه بكلمه قرار الخروج من كسلا ومن
السودان صوب مصر اتخذته السيده سوسن
وابنتها ريما خوفا على اولادهما قبل الحرب
كانت صعبه
وهسه زاد الوضع سوق عندنا العيش في
المخابز ما في الغاز ما في كهرباء ما في
مويه ما في يعني الحياه انعدمت تماما يعني
في اي لحظه نحن ممكن نضيع اولادي يضيع مني
اما الرحله الطويله التي استغرقت ثلاثه
ايام فكانت خليطا من المشقه والخوف في
الطريق ماذا
ياكلوا عايزين يشربوا عايزين ينام
ومرتاحين فهمتوا وبعدين صوت النار العلب
يخافوا في الايام العاديه غير الحرب كان
في نهر
يعني انت بتيجي ماشي بالعربيه فين في في
ناس بيموت وكده في الطريق يعني هسه احنا
لما جاي قلبنا في يدنا في المرعب
يعني
في الشوارع ويزور الرصاص المباني بتوعه
والحريق لا نحن محتاجين دكتور نفساني
والله العظيم يعني يعني انا ما اعرف انا
ما قريت المنصه لكن الوضع من جوه خربان
يعني مستحيل انك تشوف يعني انت في لحظه
وانت قاعد في بيتك مطمئن فجاه تلقى نفسك
اخيرا تم لم شمل الاسره بعد عناء تركوه
وراء ظهورهم مع ما تركوه من امتعه في
بيتهم المغلق في كسلا فهم جاءوا باقل
القليل من الملابس ويشعرون بعدم الثقه في
ان محنتهم ستنتهي قريبا تامر نصرت العربيه
القاهره
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات